les bords de loire sont calmes pas
d'agitation notable non plus tout près
de la tour charlemagne de la place
plumereau la plus belle place de france
selon lonely planet ou encore de la
vénérer basilique à saint martin la cité
royale a perdu un de ses plus beaux
fleurons son club de football pro pour
les gains en deux ans de ligue 2 en
national 3 et voilà la coupe de france
qui arrive c'est vrai que réintégrer le
monde professionnel et pouvoir réactiver
le centre de formation et pouvoir
recruter les meilleurs joueurs de la
région
c'est c'est un des objectifs principaux
du club la coupe de france voilà c'est
le oui c'est petit c'est la cerise sur
le gâteau mais pour les joueurs les
joueurs eux sont bien dans leurs baskets
en ce moment invaincus en championnat
les hommes de noureddine el ouardani
sont dans une bonne spirale l'optique
d'un 32e de finale et dans les têtes
mais le coach serait être prévenant pour
celui qui aime tourner ou faut qu'on
prenne ce match très au sérieux parce
que les joueurs le savent
on n'est pas arrivé jusqu'ici inédits
dès aujourd'hui c'était de pouvoir tirer
un gros un club professionnel
donc tant qu'on l'a pas fait il faut
qu'on soit sérieux pour espérer arriver
un stade on pourra tirer un peu
professionnelle et la communauté
antillaise sera présente à tours pour
supporter le club franciscain
ce sera un match spécial pour les 3
ultra marins du groupe alors qu'en pense
le martiniquais de l'équipe sera un
moment particulier pour moi c'est mon
pays d'origine
hier ma famille qui habite là-bas
sa frappe est toujours plaisir de jouer
contre eux sans se mettre une pression
supplémentaire les joueurs savent ce qui
les attend contre le club franciscain
la prudence est de mise dans les
déclarations notamment les deux
réunionnais qui ont vu le match de la
saint pierroise contre jura sud foot et
l'exploit créés contre un club de
nationale 2 on sait tous que les dom
quand ils viennent jouer en métropole il
vient pour gagner
après je pense le froid ça va peut-être
les perturber un peu je m'attends à un
match engagé physique puisqu'ils
viennent de loin et viennent pas ici
pour gaulle et on va avoir envie de nous
battre
un 32e de finale l'an dernier en 16e il
ya trois ans contre saint-etienne le
tour fcm la coupe de france en attendant
chaque jour les joueurs les dirigeants
remettent leurs ouvrages sur le pré avec
un but
la remontée